but then you have this ego inside that
develops patterns of what it likes and
what it doesn't like and who it likes
and who it doesn't like and how you're
going to treat me how you're not going
to treat me the self-concept that says
this is who I am right well you can rise
above that you don't deny it you don't
suppress it you don't dislike it you
just say Where's that going to take me
like some people say I don't want to die
well I'm sorry every single thing that
was ever born died so to say I don't
want to die what a ridiculous thing to
do with your life that's like
disappointment you'll be uptight all the
time you'll make yourself sick if you
don't hear take care of yourself
psychologically inwardly what I call
your inner being you're gonna make
yourself sick and then you'll have to go
out and compensate for that by doing
things that make you feel better
everybody says I need this in a
relationship I need this I need money I
need things I need vacation or what I'm
not okay I'm not okay inside I'm not
whole I'm not complete and so basically
I need to get things outside to
compensate for what's wrong inside why
are you not okay inside